[Música]
gracias por seguir con nosotros y
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con jorge
gonzález izquierdo ex ministro de
trabajo y promoción social de perú
economista y profesora de la universidad
del pacifico vamos a abordar con él como
perú propuso una jubilación parcial con
10 años de aportes para paliar la crisis
de coronavirus bienvenido a france 24 y
comienzo preguntándole perú tiene tres
tipos de sistemas pensionales puede
explicarnos brevemente cuáles son y qué
características tienen por favor sí
claro muy buenos días muchas gracias por
la invitación el perú hoy día tiene tres
sistemas para afrontar la jubilación de
una persona el primero es el sistema
estatal que se llama o np el segundo es
el sistema privado
afp y el tercero es el sistema de
subsidio en el cual le dan un subsidio a
toda persona mayor de 65 años pero que
tenga situación de extrema pobreza el
sistema público de pensiones es un
sistema de reparto ahí todo el mundo
pone su plata en una olla digamos y de
esa olla sale para darle la pensión a
todos por igual en el sistema privado no
cada uno pone su plata una cuenta su
nombre como una cuenta de ahorros y de
ahí sale mi pensión y el sistema de
subsidio y su sistema que es se da la
plata a la gente pues que está en
situación de indigencia en el perú las
tres sistemas son los que la sociedad
peruana ha construido a lo largo del
tiempo para responder a esa pregunta una
persona que llega a un edad que la que
ya no puede generar ingresos como pueden
financiar su nivel de vida no en el perú
y financia con esos tres sistemas pero
debo decir también que los tres sistemas
tienen graves problemas hasta el día de
hoy no al extremo que hoy lee en el
congreso de la república hay una
comisión que está elaborando una reforma
total y 'gran el sistema de pensiones
del perú bueno
el gobierno nacional ha propuesto una
jubilación parcial con 10 años de
aportes para paliar la crisis de
coronavirus empecemos diciendo que
considera usted acerca de esta propuesta
y en qué consiste
bueno consiste en lo siguiente hoy día
en el sistema público es así si usted
aporta 20 años unos 20 años aporta una a
un ahorro forzoso porque es así
recién a partir del primer día después
de los 20 años en el derecho a una
pensión que en promedio hoy día es 220
dólares al mes es en la pensión promedio
que da el sistema público 220 dólares al
mes entonces usted aporta al partir del
primer día después de 20 años pero si
usted ha aportado 19 años 11 meses no le
dan nada y uno dicho y me aburro de
tantos años nada le dan entonces el
gobierno para evitar esa injusticia y
dijo vamos a bajar las líneas de 20 años
a 10 si tú aportas 9 años no te doy nada
pero se aporta es un poquito más de 10
años ahí te comienza a dar una pensión
cuando antes era para un poquito más de
20 años pero yo creo que la cosa más o
menos quede en lo mismo porque si a
aportar una casa
una década y tampoco me den nada es algo
más o menos similar acá por aportar dos
décadas así que tampoco me den nada no
entonces no se ha resuelto mucho el
problema con esa propuesta de gobierno
vamos a cerrar con su conclusión muy
rápidamente de cuál es su perspectiva en
general del tema pensional en perú
yo creo que hoy día está ganando
consenso está el tema darle una pensión
universal a todos aquellos que cumplen
65 años que es el año de en el cual uno
se puede jubilar en el perú 65 años
darle una pensión mínima a todos y a
partir de ahí que sea un ahorro
voluntario dependiendo de cada persona
cuanto quiera ahorrar en adicción para
aumentar esa esa pensión mínima eso está
ganando diría en el perú digamos una
especie de consenso muchas gracias a
ustedes jorge gonzález izquierdo
exministro de trabajo y promoción social
del perú siga con nosotros en france 24
[Música]